in a new age lots of new technologies
particularly yeah so when it comes to
being a songwriter and seeing sort of
what's happening out there with with AI
are you worried or concerned I'm not
overly concerned about it but I think
art generally is best when it comes from
a human heart
um it's about emotion it's about
expression it's not necessarily always
about algorithms
so I think there'll always be people in
the world that will want to make
are from the right place there's a place
for everything in in the world these
days you know I mean I'm not against
technology and as long as I stayed in
the correct way as it uses the right
tools but I think solely it needs to
come from there first